how's it going Brad as his welcome do
not on a Friday but it's not like you
expected it to be anyway so how do you
bro suggested that we're gonna do a day
in the life of for this week's show it's
basically to give some insight of what
it's like to live a life in a person's
shoes for a day so I present to you a
day in enough found in Sweden by ring so
clear and cool so I like to wake up
early in the morning so I can get as
much stuff done as possible so when I do
finally wake up I like to have a nice
and healthy breakfast after breakfast I
prepare myself so I can look the best
that I can possibly do for my videos
that's good enough I also do my private
things of course now it's time to get to
work it's time to edit the videos that I
recorded the day before a lot of people
don't seem to understand how much time
and effort it really goes into this
process after all the videos are finally
edited it's time to record and welcome
to so after I'm done recording I like to
take some time off just to answer you
bros comments and stuff like that
alright comments die my penis is totally
not erect there right now this video
shitty
just stop mocking videos this this
gaming nipple herpes you're so adorable
joke you face I don't care haters
gonna hate
am i right and after that I'm pretty
much done with all the work and I like
to relax a little bit
just chill Wow
Oh night long all night long baby girl
Oh think think Bob is passed out and
once I'm done with that I just go to
sleep why are you hating on Bob every
time that's pretty much a day in the
life of any youtuber ever I'd say it's
at least 99% accurate so yeah if you
enjoyed this video hit that like for
every like you saved the life of a bob
stripper you want pops the stripper to
die oh but for real I feel like it
doesn't really matter what we do as long
as you enjoy it yes that was the purpose
of this thank you guys for watching
leave your suggestion for the next
program by in the description and I'll
see you bros in the next one here's the
brofist bro fish
ask your nation ha ha ha